beruflicher Youtuber ich habe mir meinen
Traum Büro gebaut und das schauen wir
uns jetzt gemeinsam an im Prinzip haben
wir fünf verschiedene Bereiche das hier
ist Bereich 1 und das der Bürobereich
aber hier der Cutter Raum da ist Felix
ist noch zwei andere Arbeitsplätze ein
orga-büro unser Lager weil wir keinen
Keller haben hier ist all unser
Equipment aufgereiht der Streaming Raum
hier ist vernünftiger Sound hier drehe
ich in diese Richtung Videos und aus
dieser Richtung streame ich nicht mehr
hier ist mein Hauptset wir haben eine
Menge Licht und elektrische Backprofis
die kann man über eine Fernbedienung
runterfahren und in diese Richtung
Großteil meiner Videos direkt daneben
ist unser Wohnbereich großes Sofa eine
Möglichkeit Videos zu streamen und zu
besprechen paar Pflanzen ein Essbereich
auch mit Licht hier kann Max reden mit
dem ich mir das beurteile und hier ist
Max Schauküche superfett und das ist im
Prinzip unser 200 Quadratmeter Traum